[Music]
is there anything else i can help you
with
that's it okay this comes after diamond
okay
i want this one with the baby on it okay
this is our little secret
welcome okay okay
[Music]
i have a baby inside me and i want to
take it out of me
right she want it out now please right
can you take it down no we cannot what
you say take it out yes
you end that life that that life will
die right it's already dead it's not
living no
it is a living breathing life that god
has created
and don't think he's breathing we can
show you that it's breathing
i feel bad because i was the one who put
the baby in her
you don't need to feel bad i was just
trying to give my daughter pleasure
and next thing i know there is a baby
inside her
you keep calling her your daughter yes
okay
is he your father yes this is your
daughter yes okay
14 year ago i released movie film which
brought great
shame to kazakhstan
but now i was instructed to return to
yankeeland to carry out
secret missions i go to america
[Music]
people make recognize my face i would
need
disguises this man sex criminal
no i'm no sex friendly
i will take this to be a fat like
american man
yeah this is a good one where is this
crumb
what is problem officer that's somebody
that's strapped to the top of your car
please in that passenger seat boss only
men and bears are allowed inside car
i'm here to give my daughter as a gift
to someone close to the throne
i need dress with real sexy peels
uh this is a bag that just goes over the
dress
they're nice i really like this
let us present sandra jessica parker
drummond
i want this one with the baby on it
i have a baby inside me can you take it
down
no we cannot that's not what we do here
i feel
bad because i was the one who put the
baby in here
did you ever put one in your daughter no
i did not
where is everybody they're wanting
everybody to quarantine so they don't
spread this virus
could i stay in your home
i hope quarantine never end everybody
what is more dangerous this virus
or the democrat democrats democrats
killing some of the virus no you can't
see the virus no it's still there
if you think you see a virus like that
this makes the virus
sleepy and then when it's sleeping
the daddy has a lot to learn my daddy is
the smartest
person in the whole flat world
and while the risk of coronavirus
remains low as the president said
yesterday
we're ready for anything michael penis
i brought the girl for you borah's
subsequent movie film
you pissed me now if he's still all
right what do you prefer you fixed me on
lifesteal
same time fist each other yeah
[Music]
you